any cigarette is a almost pure nicotine
delivery device it's a little bit of an
exaggeration because it also has other
compounds to enable it to vaporize the
the nicotine so it's going to have the
same effect on the brain as what we
found when we give nicotine to mice it's
good to change your brain in such a way
that is going to make it much more
receptive it is a rewarding effect of
other drugs and not only become more
addicted to tobacco to nicotine but more
addictive drug addicted to other drugs
what is interesting about this study is
that it began a long time ago began in
1975 when the NHIS published a very
important paper in science pointing out
that there are stages and how kids get
involved with drugs and kids don't begin
with cocaine and heroin they begin with
drinking or smoking she continued to
study this in different populations and
then became interested in understanding
is this a correlation as a so causation
she began to realize and she wrote an
important editorial on this in JAMA in
the 2005 there abouts in which she said
you know we need to explore this in
animal models in order to get at this
and she began to look around for
collaborator and she found one at home
and we began to collaborate together I'm
fortunate to have several colleagues
including a me Levine was very much
interested in this problem and we're
here to develop animal models with the
needed study in human populations so we
developed a molecular approach to human
epidemiology well in e-cigarettes try to
mimic a combustible cigarette without
any of the negative effect that are
associated with combustion a regular
combustible cigarettes includes a lot of
other compounds there's a lot of
compounds an e-cigarette is much simpler
so from that point of view I think it's
a much healthier type of device
then a combustible cigarettes but
because it has it consists of nicotine
it has the effect on the brain in
addition to the effects of the
cardiovascular system that a regular
cigarette has we see so clearly in minds
if you give nicotine before cocaine it
dramatically enhances the effects of
cocaine
we've cocaine before nicotine doesn't
have this effect there's no reason to
believe that a cigarette would not
increase the likelihood of adolescents
getting involved with even more
dangerous drugs I think the main message
is that nicotine not only affects the
lungs the heart but it also has very
strong effects on the brain and based on
the studies that we've done it it
releases some constraints on genes
related to addiction and makes the
individual much more susceptible to
become addicted to other substances